le tumulte
puis le calme ici l'équilibré toujours
lesquels alors pour les élèves rentrent
en cours
ils ont pour obligation de poser sur la
table ce petit cahier bleu
le carnet de liaison à l'intérieur la
charte du collégien qui recense ce qui
est permis et ce qui est interdit
il faut que les enfants comprennent que
la sanction sefa l'arbitraire d'un
adulte la sanction elle correspond à des
règles qui ont été décidé vaud s'est
choisie par tous et par les adultes et
par les élèves et l'échelle des
sanctions est particulièrement
développée dans ce collège de banlieue
parisienne
ça va la réprimande verbale passant par
des pulsions a des devoirs à faire
jusqu'aux heures de colle et puis si
plus on rend compte et cpe et on discute
avec lui une sanction un peu plus long
dans retenu hors de corse travaux
d'intérêt général
on est très loin du bonnet d'âne des
châtiments corporels des années 50 bien
sûr sans revenir à ses extrémités
certains enseignants des plaintes en
retour à l'autorité et les parents sont
nombreux à prouver certains sur o'shea
quand il ya la maîtresse leur donne une
pulsion parce que ils n'ont pas été
sages ou parce qu'il ya eu un problème
en classe mais ils savent que la
punition est doublé à la maison s'ils
ont une page de lille elle sera doublée
automatiquement paradoxalement les profs
ne sont pas les seuls à revendiquer plus
de temps
d'après une étude récente 83% des jeunes
estiment que l'autorité est une qualité
essentielle chez les enseignants